WELL OVER 100 PEOPLE WAITING TO
BE ACROSS WITH THE THERMAL
VISION FROM THE NATIONAL GUARD
AND A SECOND PHOTO HERE.
THEY ARE ABLE TO WATCH TH
GUYS DURING THE NIGHT COMING
ACROSS THE RIVER AND BRINGING
HUMAN CARGO OVER.
ASK THEM WHY THEY AREN'T ABLE
TO ARREST THEM ON THE SHORELINE
SAYING IT'S A SAFETY ISSUE.
THEY'RE WORRIED THE OTHER
SMUGGLERS WILL FLIP A RAFT OVER
AND IT WILL TURN INTO A RESCUE
OPERATION FOR A BUNCH OF LITTLE
KIDS.
LOOK AT THIS LAST PIECE OF
VIDEO.
REMARKABLE LAST NIGHT.
WE WITNESSED AUTOMATIC GUNFIRE
GOING FROM MEXICO DIRECTLY INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
THE NATIONAL GUARD SOLDIERS WE
WERE WITH YOU CAN HEAR THEM
SAYING WHOA, HOLY BLEEM.
IT IS GOING DIRECTLY INTO THE
UNITED STATES GOING ABOVE ONE
OF THEIR OBSERVATION POSTS NEAR
THE BORDER WALL.
BUT INCREDIBLY RARE TO SEE
DIRECT GUNFIRE FROM A MACHINE
GUN GOING INTO THE UTION US
LIKE THAT.
THIS WAS A SECOND VOLLEY.
I DIDN'T MY PHONE OUT IN TIME
FOR THE FIRST VALLEY.
THE NATIONAL GUARD SOLDIERS
SAID ARMED CARTEL MEMBERS WITH
AK-47s HAVE TAUNTED THEM AND
RACKED THE SLIDES ON THEIR GUNS
AND YELLED TO THEM IN SPANISH
OH, WE SHOULD JUST SHOOT YOU
SOLDIERS.
TENSIONS ALONG THE RIO GRANDE
ALONG THE BORDER GOING UP.
THAT CARTEL ACTIVITY IN THE
CITY BEHIND US IS STILL THERE.
WE'LL SEND IT BACK TO YOU.
>> Bill: WOW.
BILL, THAT LOOKED LIKE TRACER
FIRE AND IF THE VIDEO IS
CORRECT FROM LEFT TO RIGHT IT
WOULD BE FROM SOUTH TO NORTH AS
YOU DESCRIBED FROM THE MEXICAN
SIDE.
WHAT WOULD THEY BE FIRING AT?
>> WE DON'T KNOW.
IN PAST DAYS THE SOLDIERS HAVE
TOLD US THERE HAVE BEEN A TON
OF CARTEL GUN FIGHTS IN THE
CITY BEHIND US.
ONE OF THE MOST VIOLENT CITIES.
WE DON'T KNOW IF THE GUNFIRE
WAS FROM A MEXICAN DRUG CARTEL
SHOOT-OUT OR JUST SHOONGT
ACROSS THE BORDER AS AN
INTIMIDATION FACTOR.
WE DON'T KNOW.
IT WAS TRACER GUNFIRE.
YOU CAN SEE THE RED TRACERS
EVERY FEW ROUNDS IS WHEN YOU
SEE THE TRACERS.
THE SOLDIERS TOLD US THEY
SUSPECT IT WAS FROM AN M240
MACHINE GUN BECAUSE THE TRACERS
WERE SO SLOW IT WAS A .50
CALIBER MACHINE GUN.
THEY DON'T KNOW EXACTLY.
YOU CAN HEAR THE REACTION OF
THE SOLDIERS IN THE BACKGROUND
WATCHING IT.
THEY WERE SHOCKED TO SIGHT.
>> Bill: REMARKABLE REPORT.
THANK YOU, BILL, FOR THAT.
>>